[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
on est souvent assez jolie dentelle
oui assez souvent parce que j'aime la
musique de jazz ces six entreprises
bientôt en france et bien selon france
bleu ici apparaît de 8 ans et en france
une dizaine d'années qu'est ce que vous
avez fait d'importantes vous êtes en
france on pourtant bien j'ai trois prix
et trophées du conservatoire c'est moi
jen a bon dos mais j'ai fait le tour de
chant d'où le projet sans rigueur
[Musique]
est ce que vous faites vous prenez
quelques fois où ça va quand je ne
travaille pas tournée l'accès quand vous
avez un travail et quand vous avez à
composer des chansons inquiet vous
travaillez vous pour la musique c'est au
studio vient le soir chez moi je te
parle aussi
[Musique]
nous américains des hollandais des
belges des allemands
de plus c'est cosmopolite à moi j'aime
beaucoup le jazz
et avant je n'étais pas si mes paroles
je n'ai jamais été dans une maison il y
avait des gens ce week end alors j'étais
dans ma famille
quand vous avez envie de manger tout ce
qu'on mange à harlem est ce qu'on peut
le manger chez vous comme eh oui nous
avons le repas vécu deux mois avec son
spécial nous avons aussi de poulet pour
les fruits tiennent plus non non non non
et le rugby ce que j'ai
spécialité
pour marié oui mais moi française du
rhin près c'est ça c'est l ol est non
seulement ont laissé dans ses
différences oui je vais t'arracher paris
également très beau parce que qui
kickers par m
je suis né avec talent louisiane
tallulah il ya des vitres sont brisées
par des dessins exactement que ça sonne
surtout beaucoup plus petit mais je
l'avenir proche car qui peut la vie
mouvementée cependant posée
levis et chansons de travail avoir des
idées pour la loi un espace de tous ces
agitations de se griller n'est ce pas
[Musique]
pour s'abonner aux états unis en six
jours oui bien sûr je l'espère
au printemps ça ne gênera pas de
retourner aux défis tant marielle
sûrement pas mais ça dépend d'où j'ai
même temps un arrêt n'est ce pas vu le
monde là où j'habite mai
enfin mais on sent vraiment d'avis comme
chaque année en a aucun complication
louisiane se serait pas pousser non la
louisiane ça c'est très très très
différent à ce cas parce que java c'est
spécial expliquer simplement le sud
n'est ce pas
tout le monde a commencé l'aura de
souffrance tant les habitudes mais
monsieur vous êtes marié ici
oui je marie france cherbourg
j'avoue pour l'instant vous voyez pas
retourner avec votre femme là bas au nom
de ma femme mais pas avec ils ont conclu
un pacte à sur les murs de votre
restaurant alain thinet quelques
offriront des crêpes
ces deux hommes sont morts jeunes
éméchés bénévolat des deux femmes qui
[Musique]
travaillent avec nous y sommes seront
courues 14 ans sur tout le monde mais
quelle est la plus âgée de vos clientes
qu'ils agissent faisait
et sur moment l'homme oui maman urgent
non j'ai madame un exédent paris en 1900
et l'homme a mené à paris le croque les
restos depuis 1900 avec le même vêtement
quand vous étiez pigalle vous sortir le
soir la nuit
amadou lamine qui a un côté bleu g berne
musée à paris mais bien amusé
[Musique]
téléphone mangal grand c est aller
danser prude ghazela tous vous avez
dansé le touriste rails car maintenant
je fais ce que vous êtes arrivé en
france sans que l'année à 1200 maintien
cette boîte si vous l'avez faudra que
l'année est quelqu'un d'important au
quartier mali très important la galerie
du leinster ou au moins 35 36 ans l
appareil est chez vous oui le travail
ici dans le temps une face d'eux des
artistes apprennent la quitter il ya
combien de temps grecu thé hollies de
trois mois il ya trois mois elle dansait
encore elle s'est remise avec les
clients elle danse et même les cuisses
[Musique]
miss rose gatland vous venez depuis
combien de temps aux ars nova charles et
lewis vous êtes l'une des institutions
du à new york bas depuis combien de
temps est joué vous bah je suis né
solution parce que je suis venu ici il
ya quatre ans lg continue l'ancienne
tradition de pianistes américains qui
ont détruit
je me considère comme trop d'américains
mais comme tout n'est qu'un biais du jeu
vécu en france chez plutôt l'onas
nostalgie de paris quand je sors d'ici
que j'ai la nostalgie de new york
et quelle sorte de musique de menton de
jouer bas on me demande beaucoup de
choses mais en général je fais un petit
fond sonore de façon que les gens
puissent parler etc quand ils n'ont plus
rien
ainsi dès lors il s'en aperçoive qui a
la musique la saison un mot
ce qu'on fait c'est un gars qui
s'appelle john anderson nom de ce type
là c'est extraordinaire ce que je
n'arrive pas y jouer c'est un teinturier
monsieur joe anderson quand avez vous
ouvert cette boutique de teinturerie
tube le san francisco
francis ça marche bien commerce commence
membres de sa famille
quelle est votre principale clientèle
actuellement maintenant parce que les
mexicains ont des exigences
particulières n'ont pas de boîte vous
avez vous une autre marche club
[Musique]
lou bennett pensez vous qu'un jeune
musicien noir américain de jazz puisse
faire une carrière complète en europe
s'en retourner aux états unis j'espère
dmc ac et tout match et vous rentrerez
un jour aux états unis
manas j'ai gagné assez d'argent peut
rester pas assez pour cela pour patty
[Musique]
nationaux et comment s'appelle la
chanson au chantier c'est un twist pas
c'était blues mais j'ai testé dessus
j'adore le twist
pourquoi parce que mon nom ma personne
sauvage sort quand j'entendais christ
[Musique]